qu'est-ce qui a fait que j'avais envie
de reprendre des avants on peut dire que
c'est une envie de liberté je pense
simplement de faire ses choix de les
assumer et de donner à la librairie dans
laquelle je travaille depuis depuis 11
ans une direction à laquelle je crois
c'est quoi cette direction c'est une
direction basée essentiellement sur sur
l'indépendance vraiment retour trouver
peut-être enfin assumer cette idée de
librairies indépendantes
l'idée lecteurs elle remettra retrouver
ce lien avec le lecteur de faire de ce
lieu
soirée d'accueil de plaisir à tout le
monde pour savoir le score par
l'intermédiaire d'une association qu'on
va créer un club de lecture qui est déjà
en place
donc le nom le pardon le club 2
dans le coma recommence et moi je vais
te faire poser mes questions autrement
qu'est ce qui est difficile quand on
reprend une librairie c'est d'avancer
l'argent parce qu'il faut beaucoup de
stock
le montage financier est une chose
effectivement la chance d'avoir pas mal
de pas mal de public pour ça
c'est une partie des choses après
l'autre partie c'est le magasin créé un
lieu glissé de deux choses très
différentes
je pense que l'essentiel les khroubis
finalement n'intéresse pas grand monde
pour nous c'est ce qui a un peu
compliqué mais ce qui est essentiel
c'est sera construit à l'intérieur du
magasin les voies publiques sans les
aides publiques est-ce que vous auriez
plus quand même reprendre la librairie
c'est comme c'est pas moi qui peux le
dire tout de suite ce que tous les
banques concernées banques acceptent ou
pas mais en tout cas pour les êtres qui
ont obtenu des banques ont avons été
suivis ont été suivies par les banques
et quand on ouvre une librairie il faut
beaucoup de ce colloque est ce que c'est
ça qui coûte cher oui alors moi j'ai
repris la librairie avec le stock
effectivement c'est le stock le stock
coûte cher pour une libre avis ça fait
partie de la gestion courante de la vie
grâce à sa trésorerie
oui c'est pas ça fait partie des données
des données pour toutes les librairies
quand on connaît la marche qu'un
libraire peut avoir sur un livre est ce
que vous êtes courageux téméraire ou
carrément suicidaire
je crois qu'on a tous une forme de soif
quant au niveau avec comme ça c'est de
plus en plus c'est une scène politique
philosophie de vie nous on y croit on a
plaisir à ça peut-être aussi qu'on sait
faire que ça je connaissais pas mais on
a vraiment tous envie envie de le faire
enfin si on prend si on prend le
panorama qui est le nôtre en ce moment
l'évolution les évolutions politiques
sur le choix entre une vie sur internet
on vit
vie dans les zones commerciales où une
vie dans les commerces de proximité on a
fait notre choix c'est sûr vous dit on
parce que c'est une équipe
moi j'ai toujours quand j'ai repris en
fait j'ai toujours eu cette idée là
qu'il y avait l'équipe je pense que son
équipe il n'y a rien il ya aussi mon
associé à des mains disent qu'on a
repris à 2 par notre hellman qui est qui
et l'écrivain n'est effectivement quand
je dis aux gens tant à nos enfants aussi
toute l'équipe
quel est l'esprit que vous voulez un
sifflet dans ce lieu esprit assez simple
dans la philosophie peut-être phase
d'euphorie faut le mettre en place
l'esprit c'est un état d'esprit de
respect un respect qui s'établit entre
nous avec les clients avec nos
partenaires un esprit de liberté d'un
esprit dé défense du travail des
éditeurs auxquels on croit
comment savez vous senti militants
peut-être concrètement dans la démarche
oui j'ai en revanche militants par des
disques - mais je pense effectivement
que quand on a ça doit marcher là il ya
concrètement des marchés des militants
comme vous dites il faut avoir la foi
mais c'est la fois en quoi dans la foi
dans la foi dans l'avenir la froide dans
les dents les gens la flotte
dans le livre la culture mais je crois
vraiment qu il y aura toujours une
partie de la population à fuir a envie
d'une certaine qualité qualité de vie
qualité des changes de ce qu'on peut
trouver et nous sommes aussi j'y crois
c'est fort vous avez encore le temps de
lire en ce moment moi mais heureusement
qu'il ya ça fait du bien
passez-les c'est là qu'on mesure là
la raison pour laquelle on fait ce
travail c'est quand on arrive à trouver
un livre le soir dans notre vraiment le
sens des choses et le plaisir des choses
si sa part ce sera dommage vous avez
encore le plaisir quand même
ah oui heureusement le plaisir de lire
plaisir plaisir solitaire de la lecture
et puis après deux échanges qu'elle
échange qui est aussi à double sens
puisqu'il ya aussi des gars beaucoup de
lecteurs ici qui nous font découvrir des
livres on peut le faire et c'est ça qui
est ça qui rend les dégâts par certains
moments vraiment carrément magique